what movie or movies do you think you've
seen the most
it's a lot of scorsese stuff and
probably the godfather i've watched the
most
uh if i think about it really and and
good fellas
uh and then girl interrupted is another
one that i've watched
a lot of times i also have yeah i
i understand um jumping into why i get
to talk to you today first
congratulations
i think one of the things that i really
enjoyed the most about this is that
in and i see a lot of movies 99 out of
100 movies
your character is played by a man and i
love the fact that it's
you know a woman playing this role can
you sort of talk about and the fact that
your brother
is the weaker one uh can you sort of
talk about that aspect of the film
yeah owen will hate that he said that he
plays my brother
uh the whole time he was like he's like
why do i have to be so
you know whiny and windy and why can't i
be tough and strong and andy mcnabb is
like because you're not
um because you're not a psychopath
you're a normal human and you're just
too emotional and that's just
it no one was like um but you know
ollie's a very important part of the
film and very important part of
the character but um i i love
i love that we are having these openings
now these openings to be a lead
you know in an action franchise or a
lead villain or you know
whatever it is and being able to have
females at the forefront
of what used to be predominantly just a
male 1
kind of um situation and i still think
we have a long way to go but i it is
really good being able to see this
diversity uh in roles for me of course
it's
i'm very lucky because i get to play a
lot of these roles and i i just i'm just
a physical person
when i get to be part of these sort of
productions we all bring something
different and there's such a beautiful
dynamic between
sam and i for instance in this film and
our characters and the strength of our
characters
he might be physically stronger being
that he's taller than me and is bigger
and he's a guy
um but he mentally i'm i'm stronger
character
in the film and mostly because when we
talk about the psychology behind it but
it's in and i'm sort of more calculated
and i sort of
have i get a lot further i think than he
thought that i would be able to
one of the other things about this film
is that you can watch it as just a fun
action thriller however you want just
you know a fun movie and you can also
look at this as there's a lot more to
the subtext of the script
about what governments are most likely
doing around the world that just gets
brushed under the rug
can you sort of talk about you know the
fact that there's two ways of looking at
this movie
yeah there's two ways or there's ten
ways you know and i think that often in
films with cat and mouse dynamics
there's good there's bad there's good
there's evil
it's just not that clear cut in this and
you have a few different characters
on on the spectrum of you know
psychopathy and psychopaths
and then you have everyday people in
this film that are doing atrocious
things
uh without any kind of comeuppance if
you will and they don't have
uh psychopathy and they don't have
they're not psychopaths they're just
humans making horrible decisions and
they hire groups like myself that are in
a
sort of group of war criminals if you
will uh which is a private organization
that you pay us to do your dirty work
because you don't want to have
you know your name attached to it or
whatever it might be um and so i think
that when you look at when i read the
script i thought gosh this is definitely
happening
somewhere it has been happening you know
villages are cleared out so we can get
pipelines through them
we see that happening even right now in
the states and you know there's protests
around where we should and shouldn't be
putting pipes
and pipelines but you go into you know
deeper into parts of the world that
don't have as much
access to journalism and aren't being
shown 100
there's definitely been times where
pipelines and different other things
have been put into places and
villages have had to go or leave or get
bought out and sadly in the case of this
film
they don't want to get bought out and so
there's another method to removing
people
and it is scary and what i love about it
in the end
is although some of it's a little
difficult to watch and was a little
difficult to shoot even because you have
to
remove yourself from it especially
knowing i'm a psychopath and
i don't have those same feelings it was
still a tough
one to bite down on kind of knowing that
this is from andy and
a lot of this is based on true stuff and
it is it's kind of mortifying and
at the very end it kind of comes or in
act 3
you start to realize that grace is
willing to talk about the realities of
her situation
on a public level um and i think that's
when you really question
hold on a sec who's good who's bad who's
evil who's really behind this
who do we really blame i gotta go i'm
just gonna say congrats and i'm looking
forward to kyle newman's one
up yes awesome same same yeah